a story that
is a great overlap is this story from
newsweek about jk rowling and youtuber
vosh sparring over international women's
day uh mainly because one of the one of
the critiques against vosh
the more the most common ones is about
his comments on young children and
sexualization of them yes and so he is
an interesting uh character in this in
that he kind of embodies a lot of
these critiques we're talking about yeah
so this story is you may have seen it's
from it's actually from
five days ago jk rowling called vosh a
a a a a likened him to an abusive
ex-husband who used to tell me my life
would be great if only i'd comply but
you're making the same mistake he did
women like me can't be bullied out of
resistance there's a couple things i
find interesting here that we're talking
about one um i don't know if you saw
this but recently
um what's it what's her name emma watson
does her name right oh yeah yeah she she
said
i'm here for all the witches and
everyone like clapped
i don't know what that's supposed to
mean but a lot of people are assuming
she was making like a trans affirming
statement or something she looked
gutless when she said it so i think she
was
all the witches is that what she said
she said all the witches oh my gosh like
what does that mean
i'm here for all the ladies i think but
jk rowling is an interesting uh subject
in this and interestingly washes as well
because we're talking about the weird
grooming of children and stuff like that
vosh has been heavily criticized for
that jk rowling you know it's an
interesting story for those that aren't
familiar i mean this is the the gist of
the story
uh she said someone pleasing the shadow
minister for equality is a dictionary in
a backbone happy international women's
day and then vosh
said women be quieter and start
apologizing challenge
to which uh
she responded with that you're like a
music abusive ex-husband he said listen
joanne you don't get to play the victim
card when you're the advocate for taking
away women's rights here trans women are
raped and killed in men's facilities and
you want to keep them there because of
your trauma quit making your feelings
other people's oppression
for this you know my attitude is like
and i said this before this is not to be
cute or
hyperbolic or facetious i believe that
vosh
is a is a men's rights activist oh 100
yeah like saying women
shut up or you know women be quiet and
start apologizing like a language like
that 10 years ago they'd call him an mra
yeah and even socialists were called
mras so this is like
this story
and the issues around jk rowling
everything's going on man i really just
want to reiterate the point there are
two different realities we know it it
includes war it includes law it includes
politics it includes culture
and this is where the two realities just
clash all the time well it's sort of
fascinating right because we have set up
an alternate reality as a as a culture
we have social media and the online
realm which is an alternate reality do
you guys remember second life where you
could like
live in a in a virtual realm and now you
have meta which is like you know second
life part two or whatever where you can
live in a virtual realm so as we are
creating this alternative reality that
we all engage in every day you know and
if you're in media you engage in it
constantly like i'm always on twitter or
whatever um and then there's real life
and when you talk to people in real life
they know fully that um men and women
are different and that biological sex is
innate and then when you talk to people
online they don't know that so it's like
this battle of
which
which realm of reality is going to which
dimension is going to win the war of
what's true
yeah um and what's interesting is when
you have concepts of transgender
ideology which also is backed by you
know concepts of transhumanism which is
the intentional evolution of humanity
with the help of technology right so you
have this you have zoltan eastvan who's
a trans humanist who ran for president a
few years ago
um
you know he didn't have a chance
obviously but there is there he was out
there uh
we are
grappling with this we are grappling
with the question of what is real what
is truth what is reality and uh
you know i wonder what is going to
happen it's fascinating to watch it and
as our culture moves further into the
realm of transhumanism where we uh you
know believe that our bodies and minds
are two different entities that are
at certain times apparently at war with
one another um in the in the realm of
transgender ideology anyway your body
and mind are sort of at war
what is going to happen it's a it's a
fascinating situation and also
terrifying have y'all seen them film
surrogates
no
it's a interesting movie bruce willis
there it's a future where people have
these like pods they lay in and they
plug in and their consciousness is
transferred to a surrogate body a robot
version of themselves
and so you see like bruce willis is
looking all like perfect you know his
hair is to the side or whatever you know
it's like combed and he can run super
fast and jump super high because it's a
robot body then he wakes up
old and disheveled and wrinkled in his
in his apartment no one goes outside
anymore because it's dangerous you got
to send your surrogate out in your stead
in the opening
there's a guy and a woman come out of a
club and they're hooking up and then
someone is able to kill them through
their surrogate so it's like a big deal
when the police go to the woman's
apartment they're like ma'am are you
here and they find a 400 pound morbidly
obese man you know sitting like in his
chair whatever having died or whatever
and so
i think that's an interesting concept
they did that there's something
something with when people are given the
choice to project themselves what do
they want like they can on the internet
as either a cartoon animal
or
identity less anonymous
they just choose what they would what
they wish they were right and i wonder
if
one thing that drives identity crisis in
people is
living too much on the internet
yeah to living in your body you know
what i mean yeah i think we don't live
in our bodies as much as we used to for
sure you can even tell with like so many
of our trends are about trying to make
your body okay you know you've been
sitting for too long right yeah maybe
you should exercise you've been ordering
in for too long people have been
bringing you food for too long eat this
protein but so i'm wondering if um
you know you look at the metaverse
i don't know if you've seen the videos
like mark zuckerberg they are terrifying
heck but they look like me's like from
from the nintendo switch or whatever
they don't or like from the wii i guess
but they don't look like humans i'm
wondering if people will start
identifying as that and then
because that's what you see as a person
that's who you interact with i'm
wondering if a lot of what we're seeing
because the the identity crisis stuff
isn't just trans it's it's sort of
everybody yeah are you familiar with
other kin kelly yeah yeah yeah people
who think they're like they think
they're dragons or there's that whole
there's that whole like refuge in
colorado of a bunch of people who think
they're cats ah what and they go there
for like uh
cat people orgies and things i'm not
kidding that sounds horrifying yeah but
yeah i think
i think all of this stuff i think it's a
transhumanist culture war
i'm hopeful i'm hopeful i think real
human connection
is actually a really powerful thing and
whilst we may trend away from it and
people may shy away from it somewhat
i don't think we can escape it i think
that's i no i can't live in a world in
which we are heading towards
not touching each other and but we're
already we're already there
the 20 year olds are having less sex
than ever before more like a for asexual
is part of the
lgbtq
alphabet soup right it's all in there
asexual is a sexual identity
uh there's less sex less people want to
have kids um there's less touching
there's less data i think that we will
get to a point though where this
like this unpersonal chaos will just
reach peak and then we will just revert
back to
you know maybe if there's a massive war
right yeah maybe if there's like a maybe
if there's a reason for all of us to
run screaming into the woods
but it has to do there have been so many
the internet and video games
if if we keep living in digital spaces
then it'll only get worse could be that
our species is splitting i was watching
like evolution of humanity documentary
last night all you see the branches of
trees and then like the homo erectus and
then you've got the hominids that come
out of that and like they appeared
you'll have like like neanderthals and
homo sapiens came together but we were
different so like now we've got another
race of like computer zealots that are
like a genderless computer hominids and
then we've got other everyone else
that's still homosexual so you're saying
the next stage in human evolution is
bodyless conscious entities that exist
in digital space maybe but the problem
with that is all through history when
when a species splits they go to war
with each other and like one of the one
of the branches will end up becoming
dominant so like x-men we might see that
and if they have like brain neural
plants and they can move machines with
their minds that's going to be hard to
defeat in a war so well why
well yeah yeah yeah that's interesting
too with like neural link and stuff like
terminator
well sort of but imagine you know look
it's not going to be if if you're going
to
break it down towards who is most likely
to get neurolink it's going to be city
urban liberal titles sure not going to
be concerned it is it that is a
transhumanist thing the neural link and
so what happens then when you know the
people who live in cities are neural
neuro-linked so they have direct access
to the summation of human knowledge
for better or for worse and then you're
going and competing against somebody who
doesn't
like in certain areas they're going to
end up being better than you at certain
tasks there's also sort of a
i was talking to a friend of mine about
this who has cerebral palsy right and so
there's a lot of things that he can't do
and i was slamming all this stuff neural
link and um
the idea that there would be these
surrogates because we talked about that
like that you could go out as somebody
else and you're and he was like that all
would be awesome for me because i can't
do [ __ ] you know like and he was very
like if that were happening now i would
go move my random weird arm with my
neural link that i can't move now and
it'll be communism right you know why
why if you took every single human body
and put them in pods
and then plugged them into the matrix
their limitations would be defined
mathematically by the code not by their
physical bodies which is somewhat
randomized so you could be six foot five
two hundred pounds of you know 280
pounds of pure muscle in your pod in the
digital world you are a week i was
thinking that last night
i had my computer and i like blew my
nose and threw the tissue away i'm
thinking like all this stuff i just did
i picked up the thing and i blew my nose
and i took a sip and threw it like that
was all in a computer if i was in a
computer simulation i couldn't
be able to do the variety of of
calculations that i can do in this
reality there's this like limitless
potential of actions that you can take
in base reality and like what exactly
what you were just saying in in the
metaverse you're bound by the code you
can't you can't go chop down the thing
and take a sip of the because it does it
isn't real it's just it's the illusion
of the system i mean depending on how
complicated how complex the system is
yeah but when you're playing in video
games online
your character like if you're playing
like world of warcraft for instance
online video game you can be stronger
than another character but everyone is
given an equal starting point and
everyone's given a relatively equal
ending point though some items are rare
and harder again you gotta work harder
for the most part if all you know in in
the real world some people are better
than others extremely limiting the video
games are extremely extremely limiting i
imagine having children is like the most
adventurous thing you could ever do like
if you want to have a mind adventure i
would imagine that that's
interacting and creating a human and
then being in a relationship where you
can like
change your body at will in ways you
didn't understand that it could be
changed
maybe the easiest way to break down
what's happening is not authoritarian
versus libertarian it's not
multicultural democracy and
constitutional republic it's literally
transhumanist versus
what's the what's the word for someone
who's not a transhumanist a human
they might they'll call them ludites but
right that's the negative connotation
that's the other word like
humanism no they would call them like
they would call them like humanist
versus
you're gonna go to a bank and are you
human plus or are you based human uh i'm
human plus would you like the premium
plan the premium plan plug in your
neural link and we'll give you the 50
gift card
like so it's like homo cyberneticist
that will happen i think that stuff will
happen yeah because well i'll just have
little rfid chips in our hands okay it's
gonna get brain hacked and that those
people are all gonna be tracked and then
like a uh hive mind yeah they're gonna
like it dude but they want it they won't
know they're in it they want it yeah
they want to chop off their legs and
have like special jumpy legs i have
total control what are you talking about
dog legs and shutting down yeah it'll be
nuts yeah have you seen black mirror a
couple episodes yeah there's a really
good one about all this sort of
crazy you just load yourself up or every
time you walk past someone they they
sort of rate you
yeah right well because they can scan
like if you have an rfid chip now it can
be scanned
and like people can get the information
off your chip and then someone's gonna
hack it and be like they'll have a real
low rating but they'll make it look like
they have a four point eight it'll be
like you'll be like changing your report
cards mom will never know that i failed
chemistry now think about what's
happening think about what happened with
all the vaccine mandates now think about
what would happen if everyone's hooked
up to a two-way uh computer connection
to your own brain
the government's gonna say for
everyone's good you need to involve uh
you need to install this uh anti-virus
software and your neural link and
everyone's going to go okay
and it's going to literally start
sending information into your brain
right it's so dangerous there will be a
download you're not even going to know
it's downloaded it'll be yeah it'll be
like it's going to corrupt this person
will be downloaded well but that is what
elon musk's neural link is all about
that's part of it it's so that you can
you know it's like the i'm such a dork
it's like the binaries on star trek you
know they have like their whole
but it's like once everyone is linked by
these by these neural links uh there'll
be a lot more information that people
have but there also will be no
individuality no independence no liberty
wrong wrong analogy you don't think it's
the binaries they have
oh well there's that too yeah the
binaries i guess were like
the innocent version it'll be like the
borg but they're gonna because they did
have their world computer that's how it
starts yeah they're gonna think they're
individual the borg at least knew they
are part of the collective these people
are gonna think they're individuals but
they're gonna be being controlled
kind of what's happening now with tv and
commercials and stuff or being
manipulated without realizing it well
yeah there was a recent ad there was a
recent adidas ad that was all about it
was like women in sports except it was
it was all about trans women in sports
you know really and yeah did it show any
females it did show some but like trans
women was like a big part of it thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there is a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there